does the villain ever show flashes of
light qualities or is it just a facade
if they do well that's a question that I
think can be answered both ways
depending on the character and I think
it depends on why the person is on the
dark side you know some people are just
born bad it's something like old maybe
one or two percent of the human
population are psychopaths and a
slightly higher percent art sociopaths
they're just born that way that's the
way the brains are wired and for
children if you don't get empathy wired
into the brain by age five it's gone so
all of your child soldiers who are made
to do horrible things as little kids
it's hard for them to come back to the
light because it's just not in there so
part of it is just psychology and
physiology but oh I recently did a
presentation called the dark side of
light and we looked at comedies and
lighter films and what kind of villains
you have in those you know everything
from oh the the smarmy prince and Shrek
to boris and Natasha the spies from the
old Cold War cartoon series rocky and
bullwinkle and they were they were evil
but they were so funny and to the
bumbling idiots who bring bring about
darkness and mess things up so
absolutely the light and the dark mixing
together it's what makes drama is a
wonderful art term for that a
chiaroscuro which means that that
juxtaposition of dark and light and
that's what makes art and writers are
making art so putting that juxtaposition
of dark and light within a character
within a group of characters or between
characters
you